how's go breasts I got this on my arm my
says sitting there we're gonna play the
hardest game ever and if I die she will
zap me we're gonna increase its on one
now
but we're gonna increase the power for
every time I die and if I swear you also
get this at me likes to your hardest
game ever how hard kid kid me okay I'm
scared cuz I know if I [ __ ] up oh geez
at me I don't feel anything live again
oh don't press it
don't press it I haven't even played yet
oh my god ah ah ah
next one hey night now he didn't come on
ah oh my god I'm so scared ah ah ah ah
ah yes
oh my god what is this
okay here we go I [ __ ] see it oh my
god I'm scared of you
literally terrified of you right now
okay I know
can I get a practice one on this one why
but how do I know and like I only waited
me to figure out how to do it is to die
don't don't ah you go up no I was it
four and got at home you care to kill me
I have to go back to the green
not fair
all right this should be easy ah what
[ __ ] ah why did I pick this game ah what
are you doing hey that's it you set me
out I'm not a man okay this is not the
best idea I don't I don't nu 'only don't
want to do it anymore
this has been thank you them thank you
too ugly my staff for zapping me and
injure her and it suggests me another
challenge in the box